ok demain journée nationale de
revendications pour les infirmières
revendications salariales mais aussi
pour ses personnels hospitaliers il faut
revaloriser leur profession pour résumer
c'est plus de sous et plus de
considération de nombreux médecins
apportent leur soutien aux infirmières
parmi eux quelques mandarins célèbre
vous propose d'entendre léon
schwartzenberg interviewé par eve
m'étais je soutiens je peux le dire une
façon calme mais claire
inconditionnellement leurs
revendications dans la mesure où elles
sont à la mesure de la nécessité en
france d'améliorer les soins des malades
est en tout cas d'essayer de les
maintenir à leur taux actuels ce qui
n'est pas certain
étant donné la manière dont évoluent les
choses l'absence d'effectifs la
non-rémunération le fait qu'une
infirmière diplômée d'état travaillent
en moyenne en france 3 à 4 ans
d'ailleurs qu'après trois ans elles
disparaissent et qu'il faut arriver à
maintenir ce personnel infirmier qui
fait de la médecine française une des
meilleures du monde
ces revendications aujourd'hui sont
dirigés vers le gouvernement auquel vous
avez appartenu à ce que votre présence
dans un sens particulier à ce niveau là
j'aurais été avec les infirmières s'il
n'avait pas été au gouvernement je
résister avec elle si j'étais au
gouvernement
et j'y suis aujourd'hui alors je ne suis
plus aux gouvernés ça me paraît
absolument indépendant de l'appartenance
et un gouvernement
c'est simplement un respect de la santé
publique des français